jeff how you doing man i'm doing great
how are you
really good so how has all of this been
for you where have you been isolating
how you've been keeping are you going
nuts
yeah you know i i i live in atlanta but
i have a farm about an hour
south and right after it all started we
immediately just went to the farm it
just seemed safer
been a big city had my daughters there
and early on i was doing an interview
with a reporter that was in
manhattan he was in new york and i was
asking him how you doing he said well
it's me and my wife and my son and we're
in a 600 square foot apartment
and he said what about you and i didn't
want to tell him i was i was isolated to
3 000 acres out in the country yeah
so you know it was for somebody like me
i've had almost four decades i don't
think i've ever gone two weeks without
being on an
airplane i mean it's just the nature of
what i do you're in a different city all
the time
and and so to spend
two months and waking up in the same bed
getting to have
dinner with my wife and girls it was
awesome i mean it really was it was you
know i was
i was like oh this is how normal people
live you know and i'm getting in the
morning and
i'd go get on a tractor and work on the
farm and was happy as i could be
but but now i'm back in the city and i'm
just
missing going on stage i've never been
this long as an adult without going on
stage
so trying to put a new show together so
with what it
what it's worth doing something like
this during these times
where you've done television before you
know the drill uh did you have any idea
what you were
sort of how much you had to pivot
well yeah you know life is about
adjustments because things
don't unfold the way you always think i
found
it in my desk i had written the only
thing certain is uncertainty
uh but we had started talking about this
show last summer and
and and originally what we were going to
film it this summer but it was going to
be with a live audience and people were
going to bring their things in we'd have
the appraisers there
and then if they wanted to sell it we
were going to do a live auction where
people could sit there with their phones
and bid on it you know while the show
was going on and yeah
and try to get that item and then covet
hit
and but the funny thing is because
people were already communicating with
us online
but because they were isolated in their
homes people
started doing projects they had always
put off
so they were cleaning out their attics
and they were cleaning out their
basements in their garages
and we just started getting inundated
with people going hey i was cleaning out
the attic i found this in a trunk i
don't know what it is
is it something that you might be
interested in
and we started talking about could you
do this
virtually could you let somebody be the
cameraman and go on their phone with
their home
um and i was i was kind of pessimistic
i'm a live audience guy
but as soon as we got into doing it i
thought
this is great i mean like as a comedian
i always said
everybody should go to the fair every
year
because if nothing else it will make you
feel better about your own family
well it's a little bit you know so
you're going into people's
homes and they're trying to show you
stuff like one couple they had their
kids running around and their youngest
son decided
oh we're on television this would be a
good time for me to take my pants off
and start
running up and down the stairs you know
you just you don't get that on regular
tv
and so you know the comic in me i love
the story i love going into somebody's
house i'm like walk me down the hall
what's the dog's name
you know what's great granny's watching
the prices right over there in the
corner she doesn't care that you're on
tv
and you know i liked that part of it so
it's not all about the item i mean it is
about the item but it's the back story
to it how'd you find it how did a
picasso end up in your
attic for crying out loud you know so um
it's really fun i mean you learn stuff
you learn the history of stuff and
you learn what it's worth and what we've
kind of found was people that were
hanging onto something because they were
convinced
that it was really valuable in most
cases they were dead wrong it wasn't
yeah
and the people that had stuff that they
were almost about to put in the yard
sale would find out that it was worth
50 grand you know and they had almost
given it away or thrown it out in the
garbage
and and so it's it's been really fun
i've enjoyed it
so what are the success stories like
what sort of blew you
away when somebody came to you with
something and y'all found out that it
was worth
way more than what they even thought it
was i i won't tell you what the item is
we had one item that was worth half a
million dollars
really that somebody just had sitting
around their house forever
they had no idea you know and they were
almost in shock i'm the one
running around in my basement with my
arms up in the air you know
but yeah there were you know there were
some
people had artwork by famous artists
that they had
you know no idea how they got it's
something their granny granny had or
their mom had given them
um you had people like somebody found a
uh a chest that had an old flag from the
1800s in it you're sitting there looking
at it going oh my god somebody hand
stitched this somebody made this uh and
then you had things that were just
bizarre like
one couple had a newspaper and the
headline was lincoln assassinated and it
was obviously an old paper and
they wanted to know what that was worth
well as we're talking to them
and you know they've got their little
phone there i'm looking over their
shoulder and over the fireplace there's
a a taxidermist mounted two-headed calf
and in the corner there's a coffin with
a full skeleton in it
and i can't even concentrate on the
lincoln assassinated newspaper because
i'm like
where do you get a two-headed calf
where do you get this and apparently
there's a market for these weird
oddities and they actually have more
value than you would think they would
have
so crazy yeah just it ended up being a
lot of fun i'm
you know i try to find the fun in
everything whether it's
you know are you smarter than a fifth
grader or whatever it's yeah
learn something but let's let's laugh as
we're learning and that was kind of what
this is like
uh so what what you find often times
when you see these individuals these
people
who you know have something that there's
not a lot of sentimental value to it but
they also maybe need
a little bit of money and then they find
that they have something that's worth
all of this money and it could change a
huge part of their life
and all of a sudden they don't want to
get rid of it they don't want to sell it
no yeah exactly well that was the case
where
and i won't tell what what piece of art
it was but somebody had a piece of a
drawing by an artist that was really
really famous
well they had it under their bed
because the wife wouldn't even let the
husband put it up in the bathroom she
thought it was hideous
you know and then they find out that
it's worth a fortune and i'm thinking i
bet today that thing is over the
fireplace in the living room now you
know
absolutely it wasn't good looking enough
to go in the bathroom
last week but now it's in the living
room and i learned this from the show
there's two
there's what's it worth to somebody else
and there's what's it worth to you
and and they don't always match like we
had a lady
her grandfather was head of security for
woodstock
and i've seen the photos of woods i was
like there was security
where where the heck was security but
the story behind it her granddad
was in law enforcement and her mom and
aunt wanted to go to woodstock and he
said
the only way you're going to go is if
i'm there so he volunteered to be head
of security
and they had passed and he's got this
security jacket with the woodstock logo
the dove on the end of the
guitar and and so our appraisers had
researched her granddad and they were
telling her
your granddad was a great man let me
tell you what your granddad did
and and she just got all emotional she
was crying not because
this jacket was worth a ton of money i
mean much more than she thought
it was because of somebody going your
granddad's a great guy let me tell you
what your granddad did yeah
and so then you have cases like that it
probably doesn't matter what the value
is
she'd never sell it because it was a
part of her family's story you know
my dad was the one that introduced you
to me because he was a huge fan of you
might be a redneck
and and that whole bit and the whole
routine
given how much times have changed do you
still can you still do that do you have
to be more sensitive
comedy has changed and every comic who's
ever hit a stage
has been very vocal about how things are
different now whether it's good or bad
but things are different does a bit like
that does an act like that still work
well you know the way that whole thing
started i grew up in the country i bow
hunt i
fish i'm on a tractor i mean i'm a
country kid
and so when i got into comedy i'm going
around the country doing shows but i've
got a pickup truck i'm wearing jeans and
cowboy boots and so it was always good
natured
but that's what everybody called me they
were like ah foxworthy you're nothing
but a redneck from georgia
and i found as i was going around the
u.s and canada i'm like yeah i might be
but this isn't limited to georgia you
get 20 minutes outside of any city
we're everywhere and so
you know for me it never had anything to
do with
politics or race it i always viewed it
as a glorious absence of sophistication
people that you know were just working
class people that
even if you gave them a billion dollars
they'd still do the same thing they were
doing now you know they just buy bigger
trucks and
hunt more things and and so there was
never any
intent with it i mean meaning to it with
it now
who knows but you know
it's almost like we've become where
we're looking for something to be
offended about
and and the thing about comics
and when i talk to my comic friends
we're truth tellers
the reason comedy works is even if you
don't trust the news
it's a comic's job to hold stuff up and
go why do we do this
hey how come this is like this you know
why why is this okay
and this is not okay that's what we do
and when we reach the point and we have
because i have comic friends i talk to
them and they'll say dude i'm scared to
go on stage
yeah something's wrong it's out of skill
and what we've done we've lost the
ability to laugh at ourselves
because the truth of the matter is every
single one of us as human beings
we're hanging on by our fingernails
we're all jacked up messes we're all
doing the best that we can
you know we all make mistakes i i say
that
back when i was doing live shows i i
walk out and i say
i remind myself every night everybody
i'm looking at going through a struggle
might be financial might be emotional
might be physical everybody's going
through a struggle so be
be kind and have grace to people because
you don't know their story you don't
know the
the hill they're climbing and i don't
think laughter makes that struggle go
away but i do think laughter is like the
release valve that keeps the boiler
from exploding yeah and you laughter in
in music
you know they make you forget about it
for a little bit then you go back and
you deal with it
and and we've kind of become a culture
that you're not allowed to mistake
you know and you think nobody's the same
that they were 20 or 30 years ago i've
changed my opinion on a million things
during that time period
and uh but i don't want to be persecuted
forever
for it and i don't think i should
persecute you for something
because we have much more in common than
we have
different i mean no matter where you
land politically i bet you everybody
would agree on 85
of the same things and we've kind of
forgotten that we just yell at each
other instead of celebrating all these
ways that we're alike
uh before i let you go was it did you
shave your mustache off recently
and have grown it back because i don't
know if i would even
i don't even know if i would sit here if
they said you're talking to jeff
foxworthy today and i
and i zoomed in with you you didn't have
a mustache i'd hang up
yeah right i don't know if i want to
talk to jeff foxworthy without a
mustache
well you know what's funny was i started
growing it between the 11th and 12th
grade and i just never
shaved it and my wife and i we've been
together for 36 years
but in those 36 years i never had two
weeks
that i wasn't on stage or i wasn't
filming something and so
i just never shaved it and so when covet
hit
and you know of course all your shows
got canceled or
postponed i thought holy cow i've got a
block of time
and i didn't even say anything i just
went the bathroom clipped it off
i didn't even know how to shave my lip
i'm like how do you how do you shave
your lip you know and
and i shaved it off and i walked out and
my wife didn't notice it for a few
minutes
and then she looked at me and she went
oh wow
grow it back and so i have officially
shaved my lip
one time in my life and it was funny
because i thought all right i'm going to
take a
picture and post it on instagram 20 of
the people were like
holy cow you look younger 80 of the
people were like
no no no no
you're supposed to have a mustache i'm
the 80
i'm the 80 percent right here yeah yeah
uh hey listen thank you so much uh what
it's worth brand new series on and
e i was wonderful talking to you this is
like uh i really
really just love you so much man and i
really appreciate your time
hey and i'm loving the flow you got the
toy thank you going on there
you know i can i can get a haircut but i
don't but you don't
yeah and it's looking good you still
have hair it looks good
thank you so much i really appreciate it
take it easy you betcha you too
right up bye-bye
you